[Music]
this is John Coltrane's Giant Steps it's
considered one of the most important
jazz albums of all time it cemented John
Coltrane as a legend among jazz
saxophonists and composers and it's home
to one of the most revered and feared
compositions in jazz history the reason
why the album's title track is so iconic
can be heard in its first few seconds
[Music]
Coltrane wrote these unique chord
changes for giant steps and later went
on to use them over traditional jazz
standards these chords came to be known
as the Coltrane changes and improvising
over them is considered a rite of
passage for jazz musicians but if you
don't understand a lick of music theory
like me it's really hard to see how this
is so legendary
lucky for me I know two people that can
explain why Braxton cook okay and Adam
Miele should I get into their like
technical jargon e stuff let's cut to
the logo first so there's a moment in
the Giant Steps recording that really
illustrates just how demanding this song
is it happens when Tommy Flanagan the
pianist on the record starts his solo
[Music]
story goes john coltrane brought in the
music you know he shows up ready to go
and then he calls this really fast tempo
you know if you hear on the recording
Tommy Flanagan just cannot handle the
chord progressions as they're going by
his improvisation is very halted and
Tommy Flanagan is just like hold on for
dear life it really becomes apparent how
much he struggled when you hear Coltrane
take off at lightning speed the second
Flanagan stops
[Music]
and then it goes down is like one of the
most legendary recordings of all time
that's messed up
I would want another shot you know I'd
be like bro don't put that recording up
to understand why this was so difficult
for even a highly trained pianist we
need to know three basic concepts and it
all starts with this the circle of
fifths it's kind of like a color wheel
for music okay awesome you glued this
stuff and he thinks is fire all twelve
notes of a Western musical scale are on
it but you might notice they're a little
mixed up that's because they're
organized by a very special number in
music a fifth what's a fit it's like if
we were in the C major scale we got
cdefg
right one two three four five from C to
G is five notes from G to D is five
notes and well you get the idea if you
play through the circle you'll traverse
the entire keyboard starting on the
lowest C and ending up on the highest C
it sounds much more harmonious than just
playing all the notes in order
that's because v is a sound that our
ears just like please explain whenever
we're hearing anything whenever we're
hearing people sing whenever working
people play music we're hearing these
other notes these overtones along side
the pitches that they're playing when I
play this see the first two loudest
tones that are pushed through the air
are both see one is just an octave
higher but other tones travel to our
ears as well
the third loudest is a G which happens
to be a fifth above C in 1973 Leonard
Bernstein demonstrated this phenomenon
live on a grand piano at Harvard listen
closely after he hits that note
what are we here now that gee write a
new tone again clear as a bell you want
to hear it again these overtones are
kind of like subliminal tones that
you're hearing alongside a regular note
and you're hearing these overtones
everywhere a lot of western music is
based on the power of the fifth
especially how it relates so strongly
back to its home chord the case of the
key of C major we have the G chord
resolving to c4 thinking about what the
G chord represents it represents kind of
tension you want this to resolve and
when it finally does resolve it creates
this feeling of finality it creates a
feeling of home that five to one
relationship is present in a lot of
chord progressions including the most
common one found in Javas the two five
one the 251 essentially is like the
backbone of most jazz music even in its
most basic form it sounds super jazzy
this is the kind of the building blocks
of most of jazz so it comes as no
surprise the Coltrane changes are just
chock-full of them which might raise the
question why was Tommy Flanagan caught
off guard when he had to improvise over
them
well the Coltrane changes aren't in one
key they're in three keys
they're basically a musical and C Escher
painting
so each one of these rungs on the circle
of fifths represents every possible key
Center The Closer a key is to another
the more notes they have in common like
the C major in G major scale they're
only different by one note and F sharp
okay we need an analogy to describe this
so the way that I like to think about
Keys is kind of like languages that you
have to learn as a jazz improviser you
have to be able to be fluent in a key
like maybe C is Spanish and G is
Portuguese those are very similar
languages
that's the case like okay maybe see is
Spanish and you have a distantly related
language like maybe Japanese let's say
Japanese is B there's not much in common
with those two languages and it's the
same with keys if you play those skills
over each other it sounds a lot more
discordant for the most part most pop
music is based around one of these key
centers for instance carly Rae Jepsen's
cut to the feeling is in a major but
some songs modulate to another key for
dramatic effect like Beyonce's love on
top
[Music]
part of the reason why it's really
exciting is because you're going to a
place that's really distance on the
circle of fifths and you're creating a
new sense of home
which is exactly what love on top does
but it doesn't just happen once it
happens every time she repeats the
chorus towards the end of the song and
when we chart that sort of thing along
the circle of fifths patterns emerge
these types of patterns are what
fascinated John Coltrane in the late
1950s and 60s as he was trying to push
jazz harmony to its limits
this is his study of the circle of
fifths I think what makes giant steps
really special is it it really just it
just documented an artist doing
something super unique super stylistic
and virtuosic at the same time here's
the first 16 bars of giant steps again
with just the key changes highlighted if
you chart those changes on the circle of
fifths it comes out as a pretty dramatic
pattern that's because these keys are
separated by major thirds which divide
an octave into three equal parts on the
circle of fifths these three keys are as
far apart as possible from each other
giant steps is kind of like you're
shifting from Spanish to Arabic to
Japanese very quickly by quickly he
means like every two beats in a song
that's nearly 300 beats per minute it's
not only just like you're saying one
word per language you're having to
construct a set inside of the language
and how does Coltrane make those
disparate languages connect with one of
the most ubiquitous phrases in jazz a51
what he's doing is taking some of the
conventional ideas of tonal harmony the
conventional relationships between the
five chord and the one chord and
applying it to this very chaotic
circling sort of chord progression that
is the Coltrane changes so if we were
all in the same key it would sound like
this but because we're going from key
Center to key Center it sounds very
different
[Music]
this is why the cold train changes are
like this picture here even though
you're seeing things from a completely
new perspective and place you still feel
like you've made it home somehow when
Tommy Flanagan saw the charts her Giant
Steps he knew he wasn't going to just
have to play this chord progression he
was going to have to improvise over it
very quickly that would probably so
funny so they would it is a bit of a
rite of passage to say that you not only
can improvise and giant steps but you
can also improvise in all 12 keys now
generations of jazz musicians are
approaching Giant Steps as this sort of
pinnacle of improvisation wait I think
I've got an analogy for this it's like
you're a cab driver and instead of
knowing only one way to get somewhere
you have to know every back alley and
side street just in case it's
essentially like that still get to the
same location but it's really
interesting and you might see some
really cool stuff in the neighborhood
but ultimately I still think the music
like boils down to five one people want
to come back home
[Music]
thanks so much for watching the first of
three videos I'm gonna release in the
next couple of weeks on jazz I want to
give a special thanks to Braxton Cook
and Adam Ely between the time that I
interviewed Braxton and now he's
released a full album please check it
out below and of course special special
thanks to Adam Ely you can check out his
youtube channel below until next time